wir haben gelernt aus den letzten sechs
monaten wir wissen heute was gefährlich
ist und nicht und deshalb gibt es
überhaupt keinen grund für einen zweiten
generellen lockdown das sage ich auch
überall wo ich hinkomme
wir haben ja beim ersten lok dann auch
nicht die wirtschaftliche produktion
gestoppt wir haben wir haben nicht den
einzelhandel was lebensmittel angibt
gestoppt und heute wissen wir
der einzelhandel ist generell nicht das
problem und wenn sie in ein restaurant
gehen oder in ein hotel gehen wo die
hygieneregeln eingehalten sind ist auch
das nicht so wenn es masken verweigerer
gibt dann muss man auch hart
durchgreifen
dann muss man auch bußgelder verhängt
und ja das unterstütze ich glaube dass
wir ein signal brauchen und dass man das
richtige gesagt hat im übrigen hat sich
ja in münchen auch gezeigt dass man
durchaus gegen das virus auch vorgehen
kann
münchen war von sehr stark steigenden
infektionszahlen betroffen
vor etwa 14 tagen drei wochen die
regierung und die stadt haben maßnahmen
ergriffen mehr masken pflicht weniger
alkohol ausgabe zu später stunde und das
ergebnis war die infektion sind wieder
deutlich zurückgegangen